I'd like to start by
introducing our speaker today.
So Dr a preamp not to Raja will
be telling us about things.
So tell you a little bit about her.
She grew up in the Deli area to
academic parents. She attended MIT.
You are, she was awarded degrees in
physics and the mathematics after that.
If you did her graduate work in
theoretical astrophysics at Cambridge,
and she's currently professor of
astronomy and physics it, yeah,
in a professional life you've
been a word of tons of awards.
You've looked them up on the
Wikipedia page or on her page.
I'm not going to go over
all of them right now,
and she's given a Ted talk
on the same kind of thing.
She's here to talk about today.
So I think you'll agree with me that
she's seriously knows her stuff.
When you were young, maybe like
me, you looked up at the stars,
kind of wondered what was out there free.
The wonder that too.
And she's gone a lot further to actually
find out what's out there and map it
for us. Like Bilbo Baggins. I love maps.
I love for math puts mine to shame and
she's worked hard to bring us some good
maps of the cosmos. Slept. Please
give a warm welcome to Priya
[inaudible].
I wanted to start out by reading out
a quote that inspired me to write this
book. I had always been, um,
since I was an undergraduate,
I was always interested in the history
of ideas and in history and philosophy of
science and in particular the process
of why is it that some ideas take a very
long time to be accepted radical ideas
and why is it that some of them are the
accepted very, very rapidly. And so what
is the difference and why and you're not.
And I came face to face,
um, with this question,
I actually come face to face with it
almost every day as a working scientist
because, you know, there are papers that
I write, um, that I think, you know,
it's a cute idea.
It's um,
a very nice idea and it sort
of syncs without a trace.
And then I write a paper that I think,
um, he's okay. And Do, you know,
it's cited a hundred times,
200 times growing rapidly as we,
it's always intrigued me
what that process is, right?
I mean intellectually what the process is.
And so that motivated me to actually
pursue graduate study in the history and
philosophy of sign, which I abandoned
because I loved science are so much more.
Um,
and so let me read this quote from
Karl Popper and the logic of scientific
discovery that will give you a preview
of what my particular take is on mapping
ideas.
So on bold ideas on justified
anticipations and speculative thought.
Our only means for interpreting nature.
Those among us who are unwilling to
expose their ideas to the hazard of
reputation do not take part
in the scientific game.
So it's ballpark in the logic of
scientific discovery. And so, um,
what I want to do today is to
take you through a journey of,
of acceptance of two very
radical ideas in cosmology.
So our cosmic view has been
transformed in the last hundred years.
In the early 19 hundreds,
we did not even know about the
existence of other galaxies.
We thought the Milky Way was it
right? Uh, in Copernicus's time,
which was probably the radical idea
that set everything in motion that came
afterward was the displacement
of the earth and the sun.
He moved the pivot of the solar
system from the earth to the sun.
And at Inco, panic is his time
in the 15, forties, 16 hundreds,
the entire cosmos was our solar system,
right?
And 19 hundreds, the entire
cosmos, the early 19 hundreds,
1910,
1912,
we only thought there was the
Milky Way and that was it. Right?
And so in the last hundred years,
not only have we made enormous progress,
as I'll show you a,
in terms of our understanding
of the contents of the cosmos,
the properties of the cosmos, the
timeline of the cosmos, and how, um,
structure has formed in the universe,
how we have come to be and our place in
the sort of this grand scheme of things.
So as I mentioned,
another sort of angle that I'm interested
in is sort of the human and the
psychological side of science.
The fact that, you know,
science is often represented
as a sort of objective,
um,
people in the quest for some truth capital
t wearing white lab coats and they're
teasing the secrets out of nature.
Um, and you know, it sort of really,
and this narrative of how science
is done writes out to both,
uh,
what I think are the rich motivations
driving passions for scientists as well as
the backstory of the
humanness of the enterprise,
which is the rivalries,
the rush for fame, um,
the emotional investment in ideas
which you're not supposed to have as an
objective scientist.
Um,
and part of the motivation for writing
this book was also the troubling times
that we live in.
We live at a time of great technological
growth of a grand convergence,
especially in cosmology
where the understanding,
the theoretical understanding,
the maturity of our theoretical
understanding is extremely
well aligned with the
sophistication of our instruments
that gather data and evidence and the
advancements in computing
that allow us to interpret,
visualize the data.
So there's been a real grand convergence
in the last 10 to 20 years in cosmology
in particular.
However,
we somehow peculiarly find ourselves
in the United States in particular in a
climate where there's a lot of denialism
of science and rampant a disbelief and
science and the methods of science.
And one of my goals,
and I do a lot of writing
other than scientific papers,
is to try and explain the
process of science because
I believe that a lot of the
denial of science comes from a lack of
understanding of the process of science.
The fact that science is contingent and
it's provisional and what we know is
best to date. And it's apt to
change. When we have better data,
we have more data and things
don't change dramatically.
Nothing gets appended from the
roots every other day. Um, I mean,
those kinds of transformations
in our world view are rare.
And what really happens with every new
piece of data that comes in that adds to,
to our inventory and adds
to our understanding is the
ideas get refined more and
more so in, um, in my book, um,
I was obsessed with maps as a child, a
boat, celestial and terrestrial maps.
And, and I, and I tend
to see and use maps.
My own research work also
revolves around mapping.
As I'll talk about towards
the end of the talk.
And I use maps both as literal maps
mapping is as mapping is knowing,
um,
as well as metaphorical devices,
which basically encapsulate our worldview.
So because when we look at precise,
when we look at the 13 hundreds at 12,
12 hundreds,
we don't yet have the
reason structure of science,
but what we have are ideas that
get mediated, that distributed,
that get contested, that are depicted as
maps. Then I'll show you some examples.
And today I want to sort of lead you
through two case studies of two concepts.
And I written about many of them in
the book, dark matter, dark energy,
black holds the discovery
of other planets,
the discovery of the expanding universe.
But today I'll focus on black holes and
dark matter because that's sort of what
I work on.
So I have a site vested
interest in sharing some of
the latest results because I
think, um, most of you here would be
quite curious to know what the latest,
what the frontier is right now. And so
I'll be doing those two case studies.
But before that I wanted to give you,
um,
set up context for how
I'm approaching these,
this idea of mapping.
So if you look at the evidence
that we have for the oldest maps,
the oldest depictions of the sky,
uh,
it's the [inaudible] disc and it's a
data to something like 2000 BC or so.
And this is a depiction of
maybe the play these cluster,
the crescent moon and the sun.
And this is the first recorded image,
if you will,
that we have of,
of the night sky.
But the Mesopotamians were
actually in veteran, um,
charters of the night sky. So
you also have, for example,
this is an example from the collection
in the Victoria and Albert Museum of the
venous tablet is the cuneiform tablet.
And Cuneiform has now been deciphered,
as you all know. And so what these are,
are the positions of the planet Venus.
So what is remarkable is that they
already knew the difference between a star
and a planet. They knew, um,
that planets will wonders and they
didn't produce their own light and they
charted them. Um, but remember they will
not actually looking for an explanation.
They were just doing phenomenology.
They were just charting what they
saw as a way of making sense.
And part of this was, uh, because they,
there was no explanation for all this
violent natural phenomena. Night and day,
uh, thunderstorms,
lightning, rain, floods, um,
the,
we're really trying to record and
connect the terrestrial to the celestial,
so happenings on the ground with what was
happening and unfolding in the habits.
So then when we move
on to the 13 hundreds,
there's sort of a shift in the
search for some kind of explanation.
Finally,
some kind of agency causality for a why
you have the phenomena that you have.
So I particularly love this map because
this is one in which the understanding
now where was that? There are these
two angels who are turning the crank.
And that's why you get night
and day. Right. And so,
and then of course you move to,
it was bright and Capitola the last
of the greatest naked I astronomers.
It's at that time that people started
looking for us explanation for celestial
phenomena, the kind of explanation that
we are familiar with a set of principles,
a set of laws,
uh,
some description of the
orderly cause moss. But, um,
so this is another map, uh, you
know, prior to peer review and um,
uh, papers being refereed, you know,
con contrasting ideas and opposing
ideas were often depicted in these maps.
And what you see here is a Riccio Yolie.
I'm weighing two different
ideas of the cosmos.
One is the familiar Ptolemaic cosmos,
which was very radical.
And as with a lot of radical ideas,
um,
often it's easier to accept something
that's sort of a halfway house model that
isn't quite as far as the radical idea.
And so this is an example
where basically, um, you know,
the earth moves around the sun, but all
the other planets move around the earth.
So the sort of halfway
house, uh, because um, uh,
corporate Nicos is a rearrangement
was a little too radical.
And what's cute about this diagram,
this,
it's actually a front is piece of a book,
is that you see Ptolemy,
who his model has been discarded as an
old man that's sitting underneath there,
right? And you have, uh,
also you have the one eyed argus
who is looking through a telescope.
So the telescope,
Galileo by 16,
early 16 hundreds has repurposed the
spyglass and has turned it to look at the
sky.
And that was really the beginning of
recording in much more detail celestial
phenomena. And that
already appears now. Uh,
so the instrument's
starts to appear in the,
what would follow was an age where the
interplay of ideas and instruments would
kind of lead us to where we are right now.
So where are we now?
So what we know, we know quite a
lot about the cosmos at the moment.
We know that, uh, they are
universe started with a big bang,
which is basically a very
hot, dense state. It expanded.
There was a period of
extremely rapid expansion,
exponential expansion called inflation,
which lasted for a very short time.
But then after that we've had steady
expansion deal about five to 7 billion
years ago when the expert,
uh,
when the expansion once
again started accelerating.
So we also know the sequence
of events in the universe.
We know that there are relics,
Tomal relics of the heart universe
that you see as the cosmic microwave
background radiation.
And then we have now uncovered the epoch
when probably most likely the first
stars formed. And we know the
sequence by which, uh, galaxies form.
And we also know the contents,
the fate and the geometry of the universe
are actually interlinked thanks to
Einstein's theory of general relativity.
But the puzzling thing that we do
know is that much of the matter in the
universe is dark matter and it is most
likely a set of particles that interact
very,
very weakly with each other.
And therefore the only
interaction is gravity.
They do not Emmett
absorb or reflect light.
So there is no electro magnetic coupling.
And the only way you would
see dark matter is indirectly.
But the interesting
thing is the pie chart,
which is the contents of our universe,
is that the majority,
the 90% of the matter content,
which is the green and the
scion wedge of the Pie,
I'm 90% of matter is actually dark
matter and the stuff that we are made of,
the ordinary items, this stuff in the
periodic table is only 4% ish. And,
and of course everything other than,
um,
more heavier than lithium was
synthesized in the centers of stars.
So was synthesized quite late in the
universe in terms of the timeline. So,
and it also turns out that
our current understanding, um,
suggest that dark matter is actually
in the driving seat of structuring the
cosmos.
All galaxies,
all the structure that we
see is seeded by dark matter.
So now I yup,
sure
measure it's percentage. So
it's a rub as intense. So
it's energy. So it's energy,
energy, density. Yeah.
So,
um,
what I want to do today is to take you
through sort of the life history of two
very radical ideas. And they're
similar in some ways, these ideas.
And yet there are quite a difference.
So the two ideas are the idea of
dark matter and of black holes.
So they're both sort of invisible entities
in the university are unseen and get,
we can map them because of the,
um,
the effects that they exert
around their vicinity. Right.
And the difference between these
two ideas is that dark matte,
the discovery of dark matter
was entirely empirical.
So it was observations that suggested
the need for a missing component as we'll
just see.
Whereas back holes where
actually predicted there
were a mathematical solution,
the fact that they actually correspond
to real astrophysical objects came quite
late.
So,
and you'll see why there's sort of
these observed mathematical objects. Um,
and it's hard to kind of imagine that
there could be natural physical objects in
the universe that would
have the properties,
the peculiar properties that
we think, uh, black holes have.
And so, um, you know, in a way the
essential is invisible to the eyes, right?
Uh, is a quote from the Fox in the
little prince. For those of you,
I'm a little obsessed with the little
prince. It's one of my favorite stories.
And so, you know, the human imagination,
we've always been fascinated with what
is unseen, what is unreachable, uh,
what is just beyond reach,
right?
But there is a real checkered history for
these unseen, um, fluids and elements,
right? So, and during medieval
times in pre-scientific, uh,
times when they didn't have an
explanation for a phenomenon,
you always had some kind of
invisible fluid that was invoked.
So you had my asthma, you had flow
just on before oxygen was discovered,
and then of course you had ether,
right?
So you can imagine
immediately that when ideas,
these ideas were proposed,
that the board was very high and you know,
the,
the discoveries of these
ideas held back and, uh,
we're not comfortable with discussing
what looked like growing evidence for the
existence of yet another unseen entity,
right?
Because the other unseen entities
have had a very checkered past, right?
They've all been shown
to be a humbug. So, um,
what, so what I, uh,
want to do now is to give you a sense of
the history of the idea of a black hole
and,
uh,
sort of leading into the properties
of black holes and what we know today.
What's the, um, what's the frontier today?
And so black holes,
um,
as I mentioned,
our mathematical solutions to Einstein's
and exact mathematical solution to
Einstein's field equations,
he actually did not think that
there could be exact solutions.
It was a complicated set of equations and
he expected only approximate solution.
So he was very stunned
when, very, you know,
four months after he actually presented
his theory of general relativity,
Carl's swaths child came up with this
solution for, uh, for the black hole.
But the idea of a black hole
and the popular idea of a
black hole is really that
it's a point of no return because we
all have an understanding of this event
horizon, this region outside the black
hole. We're not even light can escape,
but there's a very interesting
origin to that idea. So in Newtonian,
in the Newtonian Universe,
uh,
he believed Newton believed that light
was made of particles. He's corpuscles.
So there was a very interesting,
uh, scholar man of the
cloth that John Mitchell,
who was in Cambridge,
who then cleverly came up with the idea
that if you had a very massive star,
it would just attract all the capacities
of light and therefore not even light
would escape and you would get a dark
star. So this idea of a dark star,
a point of a place of no return
even for light was proposed,
not in terms of general relativity,
but it really in a Newtonian universe.
And the actual astrophysical
use of this term, uh,
was promoted by John Wheeler in the 1960s.
And what really made black holds real
astrophysical objects eventually,
um,
are the discovery of pulsars by bell and
Huish and the discovery of quasars in
the 1960s and seventies.
But I was incredibly amazed to find
that the concept of a black hole and the
term black hole actually
originated in Calcutta.
It's an infamous prison and
Calcutta where the Nawab,
she Raja Dhalla in 1756 in prison,
a whole bunch of offices from the east
India company that was just starting to
have colonial ambitions in India. And so
they were imprisoned in the small cell,
which was about eight feet by six feet.
And supposedly there's a lot of
mythology about this, you know,
several hundred soldiers were crammed
into this and very few of them made it out
alive.
So this was a point place of no return.
So it was a place and it
was a place of no return.
I said this concept pre dates,
the mathematical idea,
the scientific idea of the black hole.
And in a way the storm was co
opted from popular culture.
So let's move onto what
a black hole really is.
So one of the easiest way
to think about a black hole,
there are a bunch of
different ways and um, I'll,
I'll try to take you through them.
And they're useful when you want to
under understand particular kinds of
phenomena about black holes. So there's a
notion of escape speed. So, for example,
um, in order for, um, you know,
when we launched satellites,
uh, in order for the satellite
to escape its gravity,
you have to boost it to get it out of
the gravitational field. So for example,
if you imagine the escape velocity
from an object of a given mass m is,
if that is the speed of light,
that is the definition of a black hole.
So basically you cannot,
and as you all know,
that speed of light is
the cosmic speed limit.
There's nothing that can
exceed the speed of light.
So one way of thinking about black
holes are basically their entities who's
escape velocity is the speed of light.
And so for example,
if the,
if the density,
if the earth had to be
packed as densely and would,
would have to have the gravity that's
exerted by the gravitational field exerted
by equivalently equivalent
to that of a black hole,
all the matter in the earth would have to
be crushed to less than one centimeter.
So that's how dense and that's how
compacted would have to be. Um,
so now, um, but the real
idea of black holes, um,
was proposed by Einstein.
And Einstein is a very interesting case
and I talk about this very peculiar
feature of his,
which is he came up with some of the
most radical ideas in physics in the last
hundred years. Um, uh,
without a doubt. Um,
and Edo reconceptualized Newtonian
gravity theory of general relativity,
the photoelectric effect, you
know, quantum mechanics. I mean,
he's just made so many contributions,
but he's notorious for one thing,
which is when the implications of his
own ideas get worked out by others,
he often doesn't like them and
he pushes back his own idea.
So he did not believe in black
holes for very long time,
just as he did not believe
in the expanding universe.
There's a very famous story.
So in the expanding investment,
Hubble discovered that the distances
between galaxies was changing,
um, that galaxies were
speeding away from each other.
And the speed with which they were moving
away from each other was proportional
to their distance from us.
The so called hobbled law,
Einstein was a holdout.
He did not believe this.
And it took him many years and only after
a huge amount of data because he had a
classical belief in a steady universe.
It was too disorienting.
He liked the classical notion of fixed
stars and somehow the universe being
static and fixed. And so, um,
there's, um, there's an, um,
uh, there was a seminar in 1929 when
Einstein is supposed to have stood up and
finally said, okay, I concede to
hobble that, you know, yes, the, um,
university is expanding, but then
recently colleagues of mine found, uh,
in the Jerusalem,
um,
Einstein Archives and unpublished
manuscript because do is incorrect.
Him Trying Einstein,
trying to recover a static
universe solution two years later,
even after having publicly.
So He's notorious for not liking the
implications of his own radical ideas.
So it was no different with black holes.
He absolutely did not like the idea of
the black hole because of the fact that
the black hole and cases,
a singularity,
it's a place where all known physical
laws breakdown. And to Einstein,
that was very,
very uncomfortable.
And he could not imagine that nature
would permit such a state that you could
evolve to such a state or you
would have such an object.
So the amazing thing about general
relativity is that Einstein had this very
deep insight and he kind of married
physics and geometry in a way.
And unlike our Newton,
he actually gave an explanation for
gravity and he gave an explanation where
gravity is really the
interaction of spacetime,
this four dimensional entity with matter.
And that basically matter causes
potholes or divots in space time and,
and these divots. And therefore
the curvature of space time, um,
determines how objects move, how
masses actually move. Right? So,
um,
so a simple way to think about
Einstein's reconceptualization radical
reconceptualization of Newton's gravity
is the effect that matter has on,
uh, on space time. And if you can imagine
spacetime to be a sheet. So if you have,
um, the sun, you can see the divert.
It's a pivot. It's a pothole that, uh,
is generated in spacetime and
it will impact the emotions of,
as we'll see later, impact the emotions
of planet mercury, for example,
which is lying very close to
the sun and a neutron star,
which is much more densely
packed and more compact.
Notice the port hole is deeper and the
black hole is very peculiar because it's
actually an infinitely deep puncture in
spacetime. Okay. So, and this is why,
you know, it was an uncomfortable
concept. And so, um,
swash child found the solutions of what
a SWOT child found was the geometry of
space time that corresponds to the region,
right around a very compact mass.
And so what is very peculiar is that
there is this region called the event
horizon,
which is the point of no return.
But there are also these orbits where
the inner most tables, circular orbit,
where you could be sort of in Dante
is limbo. If you were on that orbit,
you could be there, uh, for infinity.
And, and, uh, the curious thing,
things about black holes, it there
in their vicinity. Not only a space,
the form, but the nature of time
also changes. So time slows down, um,
next to a black hole.
So let me quickly move on to what our
current challenges are in terms of
understanding black holes. And uh, it
really has to do with the formation,
how you formed the first black holes,
how do you actually grow them,
how you fuel them and do the black
holes actually impact their environment.
And so this is a very,
very challenging problem.
And I think many of you who work with
problems on that couple of many different
scales of complexity will
understand this. Uh, and um,
appreciate what the challenges for us.
So for example,
the blackboard at the center of the Milky
ways a million times the mass of the
sun, the Swa Schild radius or the event
horizon of that is the size, you know,
about 10 to the 12th I'm centimeters.
And if that was a penny,
then the galactic nucleus,
the inner region where the blackwood
exerts it's influence nowhere near our
solar system,
just the very inner regions of the
galaxy is just about eight orders of
magnitude.
And then the stellar component of the
galaxy spread out another eight orders of
magnitude. And then the full
extent of the galaxy has,
we'll just know because the galaxy is
going to be primarily dark matter and that
extends quite far out.
And then you connect onto cosmic scales
and basically the stellar extent of the
galaxies already the size of the earth.
And it's like having a penny in
the center of the earth. However,
the energetics of black holes are so
immense that they do actually affect, uh,
the vicinity. So the question is,
where do you find black holes?
You'll find black old
supermassive black holes,
which are about a million times the mass
of the sun in the centers of almost all
galaxies. And so I want to
show you an artist's rendition.
Let me see. Yup. Uh, so this is real,
the Hubble space telescope data.
But once you go into the black hole,
we cannot map the inner most
regions of the black hole.
And now we are going to march over to
an artist's rendition of this accretion
disk, which is the feeding
gas disc for black hole,
which will appear now in the center
of the frame. And black holes are, um,
the accretion process.
So as gas falls onto the black hole,
it gets heated and the temperature is
about a million to 10 million Calvin.
So you'd start radiating in
the x rays and an optical.
So you actually see the dying gasps of
material before they make it into the
black hole. And that's how
black holes are revealed to us.
And the supermassive black holes that
are growing very actively and accreting
gas or water quasars,
they actually can,
they're so bright that they
can outshine an entire galaxy.
And these are the most distant objects
that we actually have access to.
And so it turns out that black
holes actually come into states.
They're either fasting or
they're feasting, they're
basically Benjie objects.
And so you either they're actively
creating and growing with gas,
and then you'll see them as quite as ours.
They out trying their host galaxies
or you have the guy, a black hole,
like the one, the center of our galaxy,
which is essentially not feeling,
it's fasting. There's almost no gas there
is just sitting there, right? And it,
it has gravity.
So it does influence the motion of
stars right around the black hole.
And in fact this is the most
incontrovertible evidence
that we have for the
existence of a black hole period and for
existence of a black hole in the center
of our galaxy. So what do you really
see here are orbits of Real Stars.
This is data taken at the Keck
telescope and you will see that,
you know, we are far enough
away the gender relativities,
it's beyond the regime of general
relativity because we see nice classical
capillary and on Orbitz here,
right? So we are, you know,
we just knew Tony and understanding,
we can figure out the mass of the object,
which is shown as a,
and that's where the 4 million,
4 million times the mass of the solar
masses comes from, from that measurement.
And so this is just to show you where
we are in terms of understanding how gas
actually makes it into a black hole.
So one thing we still don't understand
what is an unsolved problem,
although we have some ideas, is how do
you actually lose the angular momentum?
You have to lose the Anglo momentum
before you actually make it into the hole.
So we have lots of ideas about structures
that you could have that would enable
mass to move inward and you know,
went to him to move outward like some
kind of viscosity and disks and so on.
So our current understanding is you have
some kind of feeding bisque from which
mattered rains onto the
black hole. So this is a, um,
a simulation from a one of
my former graduate students,
which actually shows you, um,
the, uh, what really happens,
what are the feeding episodes
for black holes? Like,
so structure in the universal
assembles mostly by mergers,
by mergers of galaxies. And what you
see here are two spiral galaxies,
gastric spiral galaxies that
have accreting black holes.
And the flickering tells you the accretion
that the fact that the accretion is
on and these black holes are
actually actively growing dude, uh,
during the merger process. So
what's very interesting is the, um,
the merger itself is quite violent.
In the end,
you'll have these two galaxies
merge their dark matter Halos,
which you don't see here a merge,
the stars merge,
they get spewed out and the black holes
actually merge as well in the end.
And this is another way to grow a black
hole by actually literally tracking them
and merging.
And as you may all remember,
we actually saw this merger
happen for lower mass black hole.
I am interested in the supermassive
black holes, but what we saw,
legos detection of gravitational waves
came from the merger of two 30 solar mass
black holes. So, and this is um,
one of my earliest simulations,
which is gives you,
so this is a top view of a very
supermassive black hole in the center.
And you have a second one that falls
into the disc and how it plows and makes
its way into the disc.
And you'll see a,
what you see is the surface,
the mass distribution in that disk is the
yellow curb that you see in the panel.
And what you see here is the
second black hole has plunked in.
And one of the most interesting
this is by now, this is all work,
but this at the time was kind of
revolutionary because we realized what the
timescales for the flows are
extremely long in this problem.
But we noticed something very interesting
happens that the inner portion of the
disc gets detached from the
outer and the inner portion.
Actually the timescales, the smaller
disk, the timescales are very short.
So you can actually merge two black holes
very rapidly if you have a gas disc.
And what you see as waves are density
waves that are generated in the accretion
disk, which are potentially
observable because you'd get emission,
you'd get shocks from them and you could
probably get flares that we would see.
So as you all know, the breakthrough
really, uh, um, in the Lygo detection,
really the behind the scene,
what really happened was an amazing
breakthrough in computational gr.
And for 25 years,
there had been no progress on how to
model the merger of two black holes in the
regime,
not the regime where it's Kepler's laws,
but in the regime by general relativity
matters. And so there was a breakthrough,
um,
mostly attribute it to a Franz Pretorius
who is a Princeton who came up with a
new computational trick to actually model
the punctures in space time and their
mergers.
And you needed that so that you could
then template what the events would look
like. And without the templates, you
wouldn't know how to pick out the signal.
So this is a, you must have all
seen, this was just incredible.
I really did not imagine it what
happened in my and my lifetime.
But what I'm really waiting for is the
merger of supermassive black holes,
which is much lower frequency
than the lego event. And it needs,
these detectors are Lygo like arm
interferometer in space and that is being
planned by the Europeans and NASA is
reluctantly but slowly joining in on the
Gip. And so hopefully that window
will be open because that is the,
that's the signal you would get from the
merger of the supermassive black holes.
And we think that the
mergers of supermassive black
holes are very significant.
Early on in the university,
they structured the galaxy,
they control the modulators,
star formation in galaxies and so on.
So it would really be
important to detect that.
So let me quickly now move on
to the idea of dark matter.
And the way we detect dark matter
is the impact, the dark matter.
It's impact of dark matter on dynamics
and the motions of stars in a galaxy or
the motion of galaxies in a cluster.
And a cluster is an agglomeration of
about a thousand galaxies that are held
together as we'll see by
huge amounts of dark matter.
They are the largest repositories
of dark matter in the universe.
And the other thing, so that is if you
want to think classically Allah Newton,
but if you want to think our Einstein,
uh,
and use a phenomenon that was
predicted in general relativity,
which is the bending of light light
traversing through all those potholes
generated by all the matter in
the universe, then that data,
gravitational lensing also points to
the existence of a huge amount of dark
matter. And in fact, I'm going to, um, um,
clarify to you that one of the reasons,
you know, I often get asked, I mean,
it's dark matter also,
one of these is a place holder.
You don't know what's going on.
Is it going to go away like ether?
I think there's a reason it's
not actually going to go away.
It is embarrassing that we are yet
to find the dark matter particle,
but that's because I think we're not
quite looking comprehensively like we
should, we kind of locked into certain
bits of parameter space where we've been
searching and we've been
unsuccessful so far.
But the history of the idea of dark
matter is attributed to this cantankerous
astronomer, Fritz Zwicky,
who was at Caltech. Um,
and so what he did was he looked at
the speeds of galaxies in this cluster
called coma,
which is a nearby cluster.
And that's an image on old
image of the coma cluster.
And he looked and he founded the
velocities of the galaxies that were going
around. They were held together
by the gravity of something.
And he realized that there had to be some
kind of Dunkel material, dark matter,
that contributed to the gravitational
force that these test protocols we're
feeling. And then he, in 1937,
Einstein already had predicted
gravitational lensing,
which is the idea of the bending of
light because of the distortions in
spacetime light from distant sources on
route to us. We'll sample every pothole.
I mean, and I like to remind, um, I'm
thinking about this all the time because,
you know, my local highway near
new haven is [inaudible] 95.
It has the best portholes believe me.
Um, and, uh, you know, I, you know,
I came up with this analogy because I'm
driving there and you know, I was like,
oh, okay, this is it. Um, so, you know,
if you look at gravitational lensing,
there's also incontrovertible
evidence. So let's look at, um,
how this idea was, how it was
discovered. This concept of dark matter,
and I said dark matter was
empirical, right? So who,
who you see here are, um, uh,
photographs are very Reuben
can't Ford and 300, um,
these are the people who measured in the
1970s the speeds of stars in a spiral
galaxy from the center outward.
And they found something kind of peculiar.
So what you'll see in the white
curve is the measured value.
Why is that peculiar?
So let's just come closer to home and
look at gravity in the solar system.
If you look at the sun, which is a major
gravitating body in the solar system,
and you look at the speeds of planets
from the sun outward, and you know,
I have a bit of a blind spot.
Pluto still appears is a planet.
I'm refusing to let that go.
Um,
and so you'll see the velocity of
planets is actually falls off as you go
further out.
And that tells you that gravitationally
dominant body in the solar system is the
sun and it's in the center and
things fall off as expected.
So contrast that with what you're finding
in galaxies completely the opposite.
You see that the speeds are starting
to pick up in the inner regions,
they actually stayed flat and that
tells you that there is some matter
distribution,
some source of gravity,
there's kind of holding up the galaxy
if you will, are pretty large radio.
I in fact they continue as a flat.
These are core rotation curves and
they're pretty flat out to quite large
distances and and so,
and this is not just one galaxy.
This is typical of
pretty much every galaxy.
So this is just the data and just to
drive home the contrast and it tells you
that gravitationally you were completely
different situation in these two cases.
So this is our current
conception of a galaxy,
that the stellar component is
just the tip of the iceberg.
It's a five to 10% of the
total mass of the galaxy.
Most of it is unseen and it's dark
matter that is heaped in the center but
extends out to very large radius,
almost 10 times further out.
Then you see the light in a galaxy which
is already pretty concentrated. And um,
and this dark matter we think is made
of cold collision, less particles.
These particles that are very peculiar
that actually do not have pressure,
they don't collide so
they don't have pressure.
So when they interact they just interact
gravitational, this go past each other.
Okay. And we are yet to find
the particle. Um, and there,
there are many, many attempts to
look for it. So let me know. The,
the discovery of light deflection is
kind of very, very interesting because,
you know, even, uh, just Newton's ideas,
if you thought of lightest corpuscles
and not as waves, you could,
you would have predicted deflection of
these particles by gravitational focusing
when you go past something that's
really massive. And in fact,
Soldner did just that in 1804. He
actually calculated that. And, um,
and oddly that value that's
in the Newtonian context.
Whereas if your content,
if you computed in the
framework of general rights
or do you actually calculate
the geodesics of life and then all your
desks of light as from distant sources
coming to us,
you actually find that value is just
a factor of two off classical value.
And in fact,
when I'm in Nazi Germany,
when there was pushback back against
Einstein, one of the things that, um,
the Nazis brought up was that,
you know, his new final ideas,
we're not really needed.
General relativity was not needed.
They actually re had sold newspaper
republished because they said, well,
you know, a great science has already
been done by Aryans and you know,
this number was already calculated. So,
you know, so that there's some very,
very interesting stories,
backstories for all these radical ideas
and the push backs at various times,
not just from within science,
which is what I focused on,
but in the larger culture right there.
It's a rich form of stories there. So,
but the verification of general relativity
actually came from the confirmation
of this prediction of light bending.
And it's a famous experiment,
eclipse experiment in 1917
and 1919 by author Reddington.
And so just to remind you
what that experiment was, um,
it was a very cool experiment.
Basically during a solar eclipse you
have the earth moon and the sun line up.
So you can see all the divots kind of
line up and you have light from distant
stars would get deflected
maximally because there are
all these three pot holes
that line up and what you end up seeing.
And then once you're
done with the eclipse,
you can go back to the same part of the
sky and look at the positions of stars.
And you find that the actual positions
are different from the apparent positions
during an eclipse.
And you can measure the deflection.
And it was right on where Einstein had
predicted. And today this is a very,
very powerful tool. And
a lot of my work, uh,
on mapping dark matter relies
on using gravitational lensing.
So the idea is very similar.
You have distant galaxies in the universe
and you have a very massive cluster of
galaxies,
and there's an artist's impression of
the pothole that's generated by the dark
matter that is unseen.
And so the light from this galaxy
gets deflected and what you end up,
what the effect of that is that you end
up seeing the distorted shape of that
galaxy. You no longer see
the real trip. Luckily,
dark matter is smeared lightly
everywhere in the universe,
but it's lumped only
in very few locations,
locations where galaxies form and
locations where clusters form or where you
have a huge amount of dark matter.
And therefore we know the distribution
of undistorted shapes of galaxies
statistically. So when we look at a
place where they're distorted shapes,
we can back out the entire distribution
of matter along a cylinder from us to
the background sources.
So for example,
this is a beautiful gravitational lens
discovered by the Hubble Space Telescope.
Here the lens is an individual galaxy,
not a cluster.
And you see the decomposition.
What you see actually projected on the
sky is this arc and the galaxy in the
center of the Lens. In Galaxy in the
center. And when you work it out,
that is the original shape
of the source of the galaxy.
It's a little wispy blue thing that's a
distant galaxy that star forming and it
gets because of how it lines up with the
spot or it gets totally deflected and
you see this deflected shape. This is just
another schematic to show you that. Uh,
so to give you a sense,
so this is actually a mapping.
So gravitational lensing
is a mapping if you will,
from an a source plane to an image plan
and the source plane shapes to image
plane shapes.
And it turns out that there are regimes
where this mapping is not linear,
it's not linear,
it's not one to one.
And then there's a redeem where
this mapping is one to one.
So the regime where the mapping is
one to one is called weak lensing. Um,
and the regime where you have um,
gone linearities and the,
it's a multi valued mapping,
it's called strong lensing.
And the reason it's called strong lensing
is sometimes the divert is so deep.
The pothole is so dramatic that if
you can think of light rays as tubes,
you actually split the tube,
you end up seeing multiple copies
of what is actually just one object.
Okay?
So in this animation you see a range.
So what you see in red is the surface
mass density of a cluster of galaxies,
which gives you a sense of how
deep that pothole is going to be.
And you had a background screen with
galaxies that were basically circular in
shape just for illustration.
And you can see the range of
shapes that you could get.
Nothing is moving in the university,
just Fannie Mae Nation,
to show your range of shapes, right? That
you could get. And the point is we do,
we see all of those shapes and it
says Hubble Space Telescope data.
And here you see five copies of a galaxy.
And we know it's the same galaxy
because we have the spectrum,
we go out and take the spectrum.
And another thing that, uh,
gravitational lensing does is because it's
preserved surface brightness, um, you,
it magnifies these faint sources and
brings galaxies interview that you would
otherwise not see.
So clusters of galaxies and dark matter
act as very convenient in a sort of
natural telescopes for us,
except we can't control them.
They happened to be where they are, right?
And that's the bane of cosmology, right?
That it's a no controlled
experiments. Right? Um, um,
and so you see sort of five and you can
back out the dark matter distribution.
So this is one of my favorite,
uh, clusters of galaxies
and other, you know, Hubble,
so Hubble Space Telescope
transformed this field.
This field could not have really moved
to the waste that he did without the
Hubble space,
whether corrected optics of course,
for those of you who might
remember. Um, so you have these,
you can see by eye these
highly distorted sources.
The fuzzy yellow things that you see
are galaxies that are in the cluster.
So they are in the foreground and the
wispy things that are stretched out are
the guys in the background. So their,
their shapes are deformed. I said,
why is this important? And you may
say, well why is she going on and on?
So this is a simulation,
a slice of a simulation of a patch of
the universe where a cluster forms a
cluster like the one that causes these
deviations in the light rail paths forms.
And this is not light, this is
just mock it up to look like light.
These are all dark matter particles and
the only interaction you have here is
gravity. And this is just
aggregating due to gravity.
These are collision less
dark matter particles.
And this simulation we'll show you
that the dark matter distribution in.
So that pink region is roughly the
cluster that you saw in sort of one of the
Hubble space telescope images. And notice
the dark matter is very, very clumpy,
right?
It's a lot of small scale structure.
And the reason we are very interested
in mapping dark matter and you know
mapping it as explicitly as possible
catch capturing all the granularity of it
is because there are fundamental
clue to the nature of dark matter in,
in the distribution. So, if
the dark matter is this cold,
dark matter that had been telling you
about pressure, less collision less,
it will be extremely clumpy. And if
it was a different kind of particle,
a warm dark matter particle,
it would be a lot smoother.
So the game now is to sales
particle physics has not
made progress in finding us.
This particle is for astrophysics
to go and try to find clues.
And a question is, you know that if we
use gravitational lensing, for example,
that scene here, um, what's the
verdict? What does it look like?
So this is to give you a sense
of the kind of work that I do.
And one of the reasons I
wanted to show this, uh,
these give you a feel for this is that
we are happy to recruit any of you who
wants to volunteer to, um, uh, to
participate in, um, in research,
in any research projects.
So what you see here in the yellow
bunny rabbit is the region, uh,
behind which any source would
get multiple imaged. Okay.
And everything outside is
basically the week lends in region.
That's a nonlinear regime. And so
what you see here are the potential.
So if you look,
you're looking at the,
at the potential well of dark matter and
the equal potentials or those elongated.
And what you see are those galaxies
with the red, um, ellipsis.
Those are the putative dark matter Halos,
the dark matter associated with
individual Alice of galaxies.
And that's the granularity.
And this is what a three dimensional
rendering of that looks like.
So dark matter in clusters is
heaped in a smooth distribution.
And then there are lots of lumps, so
it's extremely clumpy. And so, um,
it turns out, uh, so this is
the latest and the greatest.
This is a paper that just came out.
Uh,
so this is from a recent data
from the Hubble Space Telescope.
What you see on the right hand side is
a reconstructed dark matter distribution
in the blue haze. This, the stuff
that you don't actually see that is,
they're gravitationally. So where are
we? Uh, we've not detected dark matter.
Okay. And, uh, you know,
there've been particle detection
experiments where basically it's a sodium
iodide crystal, you're looking for
juggling in the crystal. No, no luck.
You're looking for inert gases.
We looking for motion of
dark matter particles through
that. No, no success yet.
But there was one controversial claim
for the detection of having detected dark
matter. So if dark matter, you
know, if we have these sort of,
if we are enveloped in dark
matter, um, the solar system,
then as the seasons change and
our relative motion changes,
they should be a dark matter wind
and we should see a correlation.
We should see a modulation in
the a dark matter. So there's a,
there's a collaboration
Italian collaboration that
claimed to have found it
about 15 years ago. Uh, and they did
not manage to persuade the community.
So the thing that's finally happening,
which we would all been clamoring for
for while is a replication of that
experiment. So the same company that
made the same sodium iodide crystal,
it has made five replications and the
experiment is being repeated in Antartica,
Spain, South Korea, Germany.
And so we'll have to see in three years
we'll know if this experiment is results
are going to hold up.
I'm not very optimistic about that,
but I just want to conclude by
showing you what are we actually.
So what is the goal? And
you know, and in a way,
this is also personally what
the goal is, right? What,
what are we really after and
what are people like me after?
So I think that we are testing gravity.
We know that the Einstein's theory
of general relativity is incomplete.
And there it is not yet married to.
We don't have a quantum theory of gravity.
And string theorists have
been working and successfully,
they've made some progress,
but still we don't quite have a theory.
And so what does the lesson, so, you know,
history teaches us
something quite interesting.
So in the 1,718 hundreds
there was a deviation scene
in the orbit of Uranus from
Newton's predictions. And I'll be
in la, very, a French mathematician,
astronomer predicted the
presence of another perturbing
planet that needed to be
taken into account. And that was Neptune.
And it was found, and it was, you know,
as he predicted it similarly,
there was a deviation in the orbit of
mercury that was found. And Oban livery.
I said, you know, use the same
explanation. He said, hey,
there has to be a planet between
Mercury and son. He called it welcome.
They were supposed sightings are welcome,
one can is not there. So you know,
if you had to wait for another 74
years for Einstein's theory of general
relativity to actually append
the Newton completely right.
So in one case you just
needed a refinement of an
existing theory in another
case.
And a normally actually pointed the
way forward to a brand new theory.
Although it was not,
it was not quite that this observation
did not inspire Einstein. Right.
For Einstein is famous for having come
up with a theory of general relativity,
sort of Eczema Hylo, right.
He did part experiments. He
did get Duncan experiments.
He didn't actually, you know, do,
he was aware of the data, but uh,
and one of the triumphs
was this explanation of the
anomalies in the anomalous
precession of the orbit of
mercury. So, um, I just stop here.
Thank you so much for your attention.
And I just want to conclude, wait,
I'll just show this in the
background because it's a superb,
a movie that massive made on.
I've got an understanding of black holes
and a lot of the work that I've been
doing over the years has
contributed to this movie.
So I'm very pleased with
how it looks. So, um,
what does actually shows you is our
observational access to black holes.
So the x ray emission on exactly
where the ambition comes from.
And for those of you will probably saw
interstellar and hopefully loved it like
I did.
They did.
They actually solve the real equations
of general relativity for the,
for the light shadows around Gargantua.
And so this is the real McCoy.
So this is actually the gas and you'll
see the photon rings as well as show you
the angle. So this is what
you see in the soft x rays.
So the low energy x-rays, that's
the, to give you a perspective,
that's the event horizon
size of the event horizon.
And this is sort of the angle
from which we are viewing.
So you have a central black hole and
this structure is the feeding accretion
this,
but these are sort of the paths of life
around the black hole and you have
this like inner a photon ring,
this sort of limbo where
you would be in limbo.
And the motto that's calling in the gas
that's falling in his bed up to about
half seat in the inner regions
and this coloring of blue and red,
which you seem sort of publish mixing
is sort of the red shifting and Lou
shifting of gas that is
moving towards awesome.
The way from us on you
also see heart emission,
hot x ray emission, very, very
energetic photons coming from
the accretion disk.
And that actually comes from the random
scattering of gas and electronics.
So this is the sort of kind of data
that we're actually getting now.
So you get the extra spectra and we can
actually map it to spatially where in
the context of this accretion disk model,
the radiation originates from.
And actually there's a very exciting
new project called the event Horizon
Telescope in which doesn't attempt to
measure that in a photon ring for the
black hole in the center galaxy using
the entire earth as a radio telescope
dish. Anyway, I will stop here finally.
Thank you so much for your patients.
Yes.
So where are we ready with the
first question? Yeah, go ahead.
So there's a question
on the simulation of galaxies colliding.
It's an understanding gags that are mostly
empty space. And I was wondering what,
uh, what we know about what would happen
to the contents of these galaxies.
Like we just started start murmuring to
each other or just passing the night or
become binary.
Yeah, they buy, they would, as you saw,
what you saw was the stories and the
gas that was shown in that rendition,
both stars and gas.
So you would have some fraction of the
stars would actually get splattered out
and there would be a portion of it would
fall back, would be on elongated orbits,
but they would come back and
splash back and fall back.
But they would actually mix the Stella
components of the two galaxies would
actually mix up and,
uh,
you would form a much more concentrated
distribution of stars depending on the
angle and the dynamics of the merger.
And we actually believe that a structure
built up hierarchy hierarchical in the
universe through the merger of
small galaxies over cosmic time.
So a, at early times you had
an abundance of small galaxies,
small galaxies were formed first they
collide and you assembled more massive
galaxies as time goes on. But
yes, they're very violent events.
The energetics are pretty staggering.
Uh, my first question for you is, um,
you didn't mention a gravity at all.
Yup.
You start getting the reason for that.
Yeah.
Because I mean,
a lot of the work that I've been talking
about is very much in the classical
regime and the current observational
data is really restricted,
you know, is, um, we don't need
quantum physics to interpret the data,
maybe in a quantum gravity to
actually interpret the data.
We need quantum physics to understand
how radiation, but, um, yeah,
this is very much still in,
in the classical classical rigid.
All right. So second question
is in that classical regime, uh,
and a black hole, a coe. What
can you tell us about the, um,
Eric goes for your frame
dragging and time travel? No.
Okay. All, all, all of the
questions in one. Yeah. So, um,
the you do expect, as I said,
the nature of time also changes.
So you expect this,
a frame dragging this effect is called
the Bardi in Patterson effect in the
inner regions of black holes. And we
actually have evidence for that. Uh, uh,
especially when you see two black
holes merging and you'll see the,
the frames that are being
dragged spacetime that's
been dragged as the margin.
And the way that manifests is you'll
see some jitter in the jets that are
produced by. So we think now that we
have a measurement of frame dragging,
we can actually explain it in the context
of the models that we currently have
of accretion disk around black
holes and jets. As for time travel,
um, it's mathematically permitted,
but that doesn't mean that a,
it's possible.
Thank you.
Um, so you were talking about
a dark meadow, dark matter
halos around, um, you know,
galaxies and so forth. Have we actually
observed like clumps of dark matter,
independent of visible matter
of galaxies or things like that?
That's a great question.
So that is a bill that's been the sort
of perennial quest. So at the moment, uh,
we find that light and mass trace
each other quite well in the universe.
It's not linear, it's not a one to one,
but, uh, typically, uh, we have not,
we are yet to find clumps of dark
matter that do not have any stars or gas
that's associated with them.
The closest thing that we
have are these dwarf galaxies,
which are these very
piddly low mass galaxies,
about a billion times the mass of the
sun, the mass of the entire galaxy, right?
It's about a thousand. The
mass of the, uh, our galaxy.
And these galaxies,
some of them are so tiny that you have,
are either not formed very many stars.
And so you see just hot gas and a
few stores that extremely dark matter
dominated. And, and if you
did have stories earlier on,
they will probably rejected. They're
such wimpy potential wells. The gravity,
um, at early times when it was assembling
was such that you had one supernova
explosion and you kind of
splattered out all the stars.
And maybe that's why you've ended up,
but those are the kind of the objects
that you get closest to which are nearly
dark, but even they are not
completely dark. But, you know,
we've been looking always in the mapping
work that I do in gravitational lensing.
Uh, there have been claims at some point
saying, oh, we found a dark cluster.
But then you look deeper.
There's just, they're faint.
Galaxies are just munched and it's
just that, you know, we've missed them.
But that would be cool
if we did find them.
So, so does that, does
that imply like, come on,
can we draw conclusions that, like,
if, if we think that dark mattered,
never clumps independently
of physical matter, is there,
is there a theory or an
explanation for that behavior?
I know, I mean, I think it's not the dark
matter. It doesn't clump independent of,
uh,
of Baryons,
but that baryons always find their way
to gravitational potential wells that are
generated by the dark matter because dark
matter really structures the universe.
So way back when,
there was a discussion as to whether
or not there was enough matter in the
universe to change Friedman's equations
to being closed versus forever
expanding.
Yup.
Where does that discussion stands now
with what we know about dark matter?
Yes.
Well, so what we know in 1998, uh,
we discovered that the expansion of
the universe is actually accelerating.
And so it's driven by,
um,
by a force that countervails
the attraction of gravity's
a repulsive force and
um,
that appears to be driving this.
And the contribution of
that repulsive force to the,
the energy density budget
of the universe was 70%.
So it was sort of the
dominant component today.
And so what it showed us
was that the inventory,
the pie chart that I showed you,
he said the dark matter is
the dominant matter component.
But in terms of the total energy density,
the mass energy density of the universe,
uh,
the dominant piece is still dark energy.
We don't quite know what
dark energy is right yet,
except we know what it does. And as you
can see with a lot of these entities,
we actually know what, how they effect
motions. I know measurable quantities,
although we don't know what they are
and how they are actually in the case of
dark matter, we know how it's
distributed. In the case of dark energy,
we really don't know yet
whether it's a field.
It could have been a scalar field
in the very early universe. Um, um,
but there is no plausible
theory quite yet.
We're meant to act as you presume the dark
end Jack Energy is effectively uniform
because otherwise it was a clumping of
dark energy. It's gravitation uniforms
spatially as an, it is accelerate
space time in a uniform way,
but it has come to dominate
at later times. Temporarily.
It has come to dominate at later times.
So there was an epoch in
the universe when, uh,
the energy density was dominated
by radiation in the early stages,
then matter took over and mattered,
dominated mostly dark matter.
And then at late times now dark
energy has taken over temporarily.
Oh, I have to choose, dammit.
So they'll go for it. Okay.
You had mentioned earlier that,
um, what different theories,
different ideas about what
dark matter could d could be,
have different implications for his
distribution, like you had said,
clumpy or versus more
smoothly distributed.
If you can describe to lay people at
all in the time we have remaining,
what sort of parameters are
varying there that might, yeah,
so, um, so what it is so
clumping, right? It's um, um,
it's a substructure. It
is the structure of, um,
the detailed distribution,
the granularity of dark matter.
So you can define this
quantity called us sub halo,
the substructure mass function,
how much mass you have in every,
um, uh, how, how many sub
structures you have in any mass,
Ben. And that can be characterized. So
within, so within our galaxy, for example,
which is about 10 to the 12
times the mass of the sun,
the question is how many clubs there are
that are 10 to the 10 solar masses tend
to the nine solar masses.
That spectrum.
It's a power law and we think it has a
slope of minus 1.8399999999999999 cold,
dark matter for other kinds of dark
matter. It is not as seamless power law.
There's a cutoff.
And so we're kind of looking for a cutoff
in that power spectrum, if you will.
You know, these, these
fluctuations, right?
They're basically these dark matter
clumps arise from fluctuations in a mean
field very early on in the universe
that get amplified over time.
Okay,
so this isn't necessarily
about like different ways
dark matter might behave now
about more like an actual condition.
No, no, it's, it's to
the initial conditions,
but you see the manifestation now of how
it's actually spatially distributed and
what the mass function of those clumps is.
All right, thanks everybody. And let's
please give one last round of applause.
[inaudible].